My beautiful,
healthy baby boy.
Thank you CRISPR.
Hello world.
It's Saroj in a few days ago,
a Chinese scientists claim to have created the first genetically modified
humans.
This triggered memories of that Dystopian eugenics book,
brave new world that I spark noted in high school.
No regrets.
He used a very popular gene editing tool called Crispr to modify the embryos for
a couple during fertility treatments to make them resistant to HIV infection,
which resulted in the birth of twin girls immediately afterwards,
one of the inventors of crisper through some scientific shade at him by calling
for a global moratorium on using it to create gene edited babies.
MMM.
This
fiasco has brought some really hard questions in biotechnology to the limelight
that I'm going to address.
Should we be engineering our own biology and that of our offspring.
What are the other potentials for this technology and what does it even mean to
be human?
In 1919 to Hungarian agricultural engineer Carl Iraqi key saw a time when
biology could be used to turn raw materials into useful products.
He coined the term biotechnology to describe the merging of biology and
technology.
We can consider agriculture to be a form of early biotech.
When farmers introduced their plans to new environments and selectively bred
them with others,
they inadvertently altered their genetics.
Also brewing beers,
so hipsters are basically biotechnologists and after more than 40 years of
running on parallel tracks,
the information and life sciences are slowly beginning to fuse into a single
technological and economic force.
We're using computers to decipher,
manage,
and organize that amounts of genetic data,
which is the raw resource of the emerging biotech economy.
A wreck.
He's vision has now been realized.
We are at the stage where we're able to program living systems and organisms to
solve problems and make products introducing glow in the dark water.
Thousands of biotechnology startups are popping up across the world with
products like new medicines,
medical devices,
resilient crops,
biofuels and pollution controls.
We're creating biological data banks using genetic information of millions of
years of evolution to remake the natural world.
The breakthrough that laid the groundwork for modern biotechnology came when the
structure of DNA was discovered by Watson and Crick in the early 1950s DNA is a
long coiled molecule found in the center of a cell.
It provides the full blueprint for the construction and operation of a life form
be a minuscule microbe,
an elephant,
or even a human.
Every cell in an organism holds complete copy of that organism's DNA.
That data in DNA is not stored as ones and zeros as it is on silicon chips,
but instead,
as code made up of four basic building blocks,
a c t and g called nucleotides.
The order they appear is like the order of the letters that spell words.
Their order forms different genes and each gene contains the instructions for a
specific protein.
The genes in the DNA of a cell can be either active or inactive depending on the
cells needs.
Once a gene is active,
it's data is used to make the protein for which it coats.
Proteins can put molecules together,
break them apart,
relay messages between cells,
act as antibodies to defend against diseases or act as structural building
blocks,
giving shape to cells and organs.
Now you can retake your bio exam and pass.
Bio Technology is advancing really fast these days due to two reasons.
Ai and crisper.
For example,
IBM's Watson.
Ai Uses an ensemble of different machine learning models to derive insights from
data and in a demo was fed 70 k papers published around one single protein.
What would have taken a well trained human years to understand Watson was able
to do instantly.
It integrated the data,
created a map of interaction and added seven new protein interactions that
humans later discovered independently.
And then there's crisper scientists usually don't like using the word miracle,
but it seems like they make an exception when it comes to this crisply named
gene editing tool.
Crispr stands for clustered regularly.
Interspaced short palindromic repeats.
Yeah,
the name sounds ridiculous.
I know it refers to unusual DNA sequences that help protect organisms by
identifying threats like viruses and attacking them.
When we look at the DNA sequences themselves,
they are clustered.
They are spaced out at clear intervals and when assigned letter values they do
look like short palindromes repeating over and over with slight variation.
Bacteria uses these repeats like collections of mugshots to identify bad viruses
and another crucial component here is cas nine this is an enzyme that can cut
apart DNA bacteria fight viruses by sending the CAS nine enzyme to cut up
viruses that have a mugshot in the collection.
Researchers have used a similar approach to turn this micro virus fighting
system into the hottest new lab tool.
An organism's genome.
The entire set of its DNA instructions can be altered quickly and efficiently.
Using Crispr,
it's low cost,
easy to use.
In fact,
you can buy a $150 kit to use CRISPR at home.
Some middle schoolers are already doing it in their science classes and all I
got to do was cut open a frog for those who don't want to conduct experiments
locally.
Cloud labs like transcriptomic makes it possible to do so remotely using
robotics.
It automates the tedious stuff like tool building,
which lets aspiring bio data scientists focus on answering questions.
Crispr and cas nine works as a homing device that guides molecular scissors to a
target selection of DNA.
It's like a computer mouse just point at the place in the genome and you can do
anything you want at that spot.
Both the cost of gene sequencing technology and computer processing power has
dropped dramatically allowing for this field to flourish.
The question then becomes,
how can we engineer our world with biotechnology?
Well,
to start by ending hunger,
huge questions.
Vex the future of food.
How do we feed 9 billion people?
How do we form in an era of unprecedented climate uncertainty?
Will Starbucks survive in Italy?
No.
So far genetically modified organisms or GMOs have been used to help feed the
world's hungry,
but they are still not seen as a sustainable solution by some governments
because it involves inserting desired foreign genes into the existing genome of
a plant or animal,
but gene editing techniques,
namely CRISPR instead modifies the organism directly without introducing foreign
genetic material,
which allows for a new realm of both legal and scientific possibility.
In Subsaharan,
Senegal,
researchers tested thousands of wheat varieties using CRISPR before developing
wheat.
That could flourish.
Despite heat hovering constantly above 100 degrees Fahrenheit.
They're wheat yield,
required less water and had five times more protein as well as more vitamins and
minerals than Senegalese rights.
All Right,
I'm getting hungry now,
but look,
we can use CRISPR to protect and repair the environment from any harm we cause.
One example,
our biofuels plants naturally turned carbon dioxide and sunlight into
byproducts.
With crisper we can use the sugars that's or alcohol is produced by them as
potential alternative fuel sources.
We can even turn plans into sensors.
They already are naturally by responding to chemicals in their environment,
but by re-engineering them we can get them to signal the presence of
environmental pollutants and once identified,
it could trigger a bio remediation pathway and we can think about environmental
sustainability in an entirely new way.
In the form of bio design,
people are already modifying genes to redesign extinct species,
make plans,
glow in the dark and help flowers change color depending on the time of day.
Adidas even made a shoe from bio engineered fiber,
which was inspired by spider silk,
still cheaper than Yeezys.
Taking it a step further.
We could theoretically engineer a tree's DNA to grow into a tree house or even
engineer entire cities to be built from an around nature,
living harmoniously with it,
and if we can engineer physical objects and living things with DNA,
why not create computers out of it?
Instead of silicon?
A cryptographer named Bernard Adelman use DNA to solve the traveling salesman
problem.
The goal is to find the shortest route between a number of cities by going
through each city.
Once Adelman was able to show that billions of molecules in a single drop of DNA
can be used for computing.
He represented seven cities in the strands of DNA,
the sequences of genetic alphabets,
a s,
a,
t c and g represented cities.
And the path he mixed the DNA molecules in a test tube.
Some strands stuck together and chains of strands where the possible answers he
eliminated the wrong molecules using chemical reactions and what was left was
the optimal answer.
I know this makes c plus plus programming seem easy,
a f,
but DNA molecules are able to store billions of times more data than silicon
devices.
It's abundant,
cheap,
environmentally friendly and compact.
We can use DNA for both storage and computing.
Eventually replacing entire server farms with a box that fits in the size of
your palm,
but democratizing technology of any kind has potential risks.
If gene editing becomes easily accessible to anyone via CRISPR,
it could be used as a tool by aspiring biological terrorists.
They could use it to grow and disseminate lethal chemicals or other pests onto a
population of people.
The UN drafted an agreement called the biological and Toxin Weapons Convention
where countries agreed to never under any circumstance acquire or retain
biological weapons.
It's just a start,
but if governments are on board,
it makes it much harder for rogue agents to synthesize harmful material.
So far,
the possibilities we've discussed only include engineering our outer world using
biotechnology,
but the most exciting potential of biotechnology is engineering our inner world,
meaning not gene therapy,
but gene enhancement.
There are over 10 k diseases caused by mutations in a single gene known as
monogenic diseases and many more caused by mutations in multiple genes.
We can use gene editing to cure these diseases.
Sin Gamo Therapeutics,
for example,
help demand with hunter syndrome by injecting him with their replacement copy of
his flaw gene,
but why and at curing diseases,
why not cure death itself?
If we could choose when to die rather than succumb to a genetically
predetermined death,
it would give us much more of an opportunity to experience life.
Some say that death is the only motivation to do great things in life,
but why assume it's like that for all people.
Curiosity,
competition,
spicy ramen.
There are a wide variety of motivations for people.
Rejuvenate bio is a startup that has plans to reverse aging in dogs.
Then reverse aging in humans.
They've used gene therapy to add additional instructions into the DNA of aged
mice and use these instructions to regulate and modify the activity of various
genes.
They're plan is to increase or inhibit gene expression depending on its
contribution to aging.
In an attempt to restore the production of secreted molecules to youthful
levels,
we could also modify genes to theoretically make ourselves more fit,
smarter,
more attractive.
An ex NASA scientists was inspired by a report from China about the first gene
edited dog that grew muscles and injected himself in front of a live audience
with a gene he edited to prevent his Myostatin genes from inhibiting his muscle
growth.
And that brings us to the Chinese scientist who claimed to have created the
first genetically modified babies to be HIV resistant.
Parents can theoretically use gene editing technology to create the ideal type
of child in their eyes.
They can enjoy raising a super genius.
You grows up to be faster than who,
same bolts,
more beautiful than Lana del Rey and more creative than Sheil above somehow.
But should we be modifying humans at an early age in a world where that's
possible and it is fast becoming a reality?
Some people will and their children will have a clear advantage over the rest.
In fact,
someday it could be considered morally outrageous to not use gene enhancement on
your child to help them keep up with an increasingly information dense and fast
paced society.
And wild genetic data will give people the power to predict and plan their lives
in ways.
Never before possible.
It could also be used by governments and employers to determine insurance
premiums,
employment prospects,
and give rise to a new form of discrimination based on a genetic profile.
Our very notion of equity could be transformed.
Meritocracy could be transformed into Jenna talk cracy where people are
categorized by their geno type.
Think of it like an informal biological caste system.
Indians know what I'm talking about here.
Let's not do that again.
Legal safeguards are usually put in place to prevent them from discriminating
against features.
We can't control like race and sexuality,
but they do discriminate.
What we can control,
like our education level and work experience.
If we can control our genetic profile,
why wouldn't they?
In a world where it's accessible to everyone,
this could quickly become a reality.
We need to make these tools widely available and begin the process of educating
the population on them today and if we can engineer ourselves our basic biology,
what does a future human look like?
Currently,
we all have hundreds of cognitive biases that can't control and are well suited
for the world of our hunter gatherer ancestors,
but in an increasingly interconnected and globalized world where we can interact
with people thousands of kilometers away instantly.
Global security demands a more inclusive,
impartial and intellectually sophisticated conception of us that embraces all
sentient beings.
A hyper developed capacity for empathic understanding could be theoretically
engineered and genetically synthesized.
Think of it like empathy in a pill form.
Okay.
I made myself cringe a bit,
but I'm serious.
As we extend our lifespan,
we are changing so much of our society so fast or engineering everything and
biology.
The fundamental building block of life is next.
Some of us define being human as our limitations.
I prefer to define us as a species that seeks and succeeds in going beyond our
limitations.
The humans of the future won't need to get drunk or stoned.
Their wellbeing will infuse ideas,
modes of introspection,
varieties of selfhood and whole new sense modalities that haven't even been
dreamt of today.
While the prospect of altering the genes of people has caused a rift in the
scientific community.
This type of research is happening all over the world and we are on the verge of
finally being able to modify our own evolution.
The question of the century then is can we use this new super power in a
responsible way that will benefit the planet and its people?
We can't leave this huge decision to just doctors or just politicians if we
don't figure out how to ensure that everyone will benefit from the potential a
bio technologies like Crispr,
we risk the creation of a genetic underclass that has to struggle to compete
with the genetically modified offspring of the rich wizards.
It's up to us collectively to get this right.
We are blessed to have both an enthusiasm for technology and an interest in how
to use it to benefit the world alone.
We are strong,
but if we work together a future more bright than any of us could have imagined
is just beyond the horizon.
What do you think of biotechnology?
Does it excite you to let me know in the comments section,
please subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to upload my DNA,
so thanks for watching.